تطرقت لوفيجارو الفرنسيه الى الصعوبات
الميدانيه التي يواجهها الجيش الاسرائيلي
في غزه على الرغم من انه دمر ما لا يقل عن
100 الف مبنى ودعائه بانه قضى على قدرات
حماس في شمال القطاع وفي وصفها لشراسه
المعارك الميدانيه قالت لوفيغارو ان غزه
ستضاف لقائمه المعارك التي دخلت التاريخ
الحديث مثل ستالينغراد
وبرلين الى مجله فورين بوليسي ونقرا فيها
للكاتب هاورد فرانش ان المسؤولين
الاسرائيلي ماضون في سياسات ستفضي في
نهايه المطاف الى تطهير قطاع غزه من سكانه
وقال الكاتب ان الرئيس بايدن يستطيع كبح
جماح اسرائيل مضيفا ان الوقت لم يفت ليفعل
ذلك على الرغم من ان سجل ادارته في فعل
ذلك هزيل ايشان ثارور قال في الواشنطن
بوست ان حرب اسرائيل على غزه قادت الى
مذبحه بحق الصحفيين ووصف الكاتب مراسل
الجزيره وائل الدحدوح بانه رمز للكارثه
التي تضرب القطاع واحد بوجوهها الاكثر
شهره ولفت الكاتب الى بعض الرسائل الدافئه
التي تبادلها وائل ونجله الراحل حمزه قبيل
ان تقتله اسرائيل قائلا ان حاله عائله
الدحدوح تختزل مراره ماس الاف العائلات في
غزه في موقع اوريو 21 يحاول الكاتب
الفرنسي الين جريش والتونسيه ساره جريرا
تشريح اخفاقات الاعلام الغربي في تغطيته
لحرب غزه يشير التحليل الى انحياز المقصود
في المصطلحات والاوصاف وفي ترتيب الاخبار
وصياغتها وغير ذلك مما يفضي في نهايه
المطاف الى تعزيز السرديه الاسرائيليه
ويضيف الكاتبان ان الاعلام الغربيه لم
يتردد ابدا في ادانه الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا مثلا في مجله تايم الامريكيه
قالت ياسمين سرحان ان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو لا يملك خطه
لما بعد الحرب في غزه ولا يحق له الحديث
عما بات يسمى اليوم التالي ترى الكاتبه ان
نتنياهو لم يتصدى لدعوات وزرائه المتطرفين
لتهجير سكان غزه واعاده احتلالها وفي
الوقت نفسه لم يتبنى دعوات معتدله لحلول
ممكنه وفي هذا دليل على ارتباكه وهشاشه
موقفه
السياسي في تحقيق من مناطق الحدود مع
لبنان قالت صحيفه ارت ان حياه السكان
القليلين الذين فضلوا البقاء باتت معلقه
بما سيحدث في المدى القريب حتى حياه
الجنود المنتشرين هناك معلقه هي الاخرى
بقرارات الساسه في تلي ابيب وقيادات حزب
الله وفق صحيف التي تلفت الى كثافه
التحصينات العسكريه الاسرائيليه مضيفه ان
المدنيين والجنود تعودوا على ما سمته
روتين حزب الله في اطلاق القذائف لكنهم
عاجزون عن التكيف مع حياه معلقه وفق
تعبيرها